is that the end of the matter no so much
frothing so much
gnashing of teeth in westminster over
the past few months but boris johnson
ultimately has received one fixed
penalty notice surely it's not the
position of the labour party that the
prime minister should resign over 1fpm
good to see you well no our response has
been the prime minister should resign
because he's continually
failed to take any responsibility over
this and because he's lied repeatedly to
parliament
time and time and time again he didn't
just say that he didn't know that he was
breaking the rules he actually said of
course we'll all remember previously
that there were definitely no parties
that none of this took place
and just month after month we've seen
those attempts at justification of
blaming other people and meanwhile while
his party's been focused relentlessly on
trying to protect boris johnson
it should have been focused relentlessly
on dealing with the cost of living
crisis and the conservatives just seem
to be totally paralyzed right now
apparently they're arguing with each
other not just over boris johnson's
conduct but also over whether they
should introduce a windfall tax to get
people's bills down well labour's
focused on those measures actually
helping people right now and having a
government that can get a grip and it's
pretty clear that the conservatives
under boris johnson simply can't he does
have to go
sure
and you can continue to make that point
you can continue to push for him to
resign but i'm telling you now he's not
going to resign he's made that perfectly
clear so i wonder where this goes next i
mean we are expecting there to be some
revelations in the su grey report but
you know absent the prime minister
wearing a hat with happy birthday
holding up a sign saying i'm at a party
i mean there isn't going to be a way
that you're going to get rid of him
well ultimately we will keep making that
call because we need to have
a politics that's based on integrity
that actually is a force for good and i
think so many people watching all of
this remembering back to those times the
sacrifices they made the things they
weren't able to do
with their relatives
really difficult circumstances during
that period they'll be looking at a
situation where downing street is the
most fine location in all of britain now
and it is very very upsetting for them
but as i said the major consequence of
this and it will continue for as long as
boris johnson leads the conservative
party is that that party seems to be
unable to take pretty basic decisions i
mean labour's been calling for that
windfall tax to get people's bills down
for many many months we've been calling
for vat to be taken off energy bills
again for many months and yet the
conservatives don't be able to don't
seem to be able to take that very basic
decision there's dysfunction at the
heart of the conservatives right now and
it seems like that's going to continue
until they get rid of their leader i
mean mr
anyone who watched any of the coverage
that kay burley and team produced this
week from wigan can be in little doubt
that there is a very significant and
serious cost of living crisis that is
cutting across society however i i do
wonder if perhaps we're being slightly
too gloom and gloom this early in the
kind of the the economic cycle the ons
figures out today showing you know
retail retail volumes up by 1.2 percent
dashing dashing expectation from
economists i mean what do you make of
that
well of course we want to see
every part of our economy growing you
know labour said that we want to be
buying making and selling far more in
our own country we're really ambitious
for our economy and we said we want to
see for example a climate investment
pledge to be attracting those high-paid
high-skilled jobs to our country that so
often have not been coming to our
country so we are ambitious for our
economy but ultimately we're also very
clear that for many people right now
that cost a living crisis it's not
something abstract out there it's what's
waking them up in the middle of the
night when they're thinking oh my
goodness how am i going to cover my
bills it's a huge problem for millions
of people because we're not just seeing
those energy bills going up of course
we're also seeing so many other prices
going up and you know just again i would
say why on earth have we got a
government that believes putting
national insurance up on working people
right now is a way to deal with that
cost of living crisis that's a wrong tax
increase at the wrong time and labour
would scrap that right now because we
want to be supporting people in these
difficult times
in one breath on the programme this
morning i've been discussing people who
are literally making decisions between
feeding themselves and feeding their
children putting the heating on or
perhaps not having any food for a couple
of days and then in another breath
reporting on the sunday times rich list
we have seen an expansion of the number
of billionaires in this country
and rishi sunak has made her onto it do
you think that someone who is on the
sunday times rich list can be chancellor
whilst we're going through a cost of
living crisis
well i think he could be if he was
willing to take the decisions necessary
to support people right now but he's not
been willing i mean i think there have
been about seven different opportunities
since we were in these circumstances
when he could for example have put that
windfall tax in place when he could have
scrapped vat on energy something labor's
called for that would actually be paid
for through those inflated vat receipts
you know everything labor has been
calling for has been fully costed but
the chancellor's refused to put it into
practice and i have to say i think the
clearest example of where his priorities
lie is in the fact that the
conservatives have refused to get rid of
non-dom status that status that protects
often very wealthy people's wealth from
taxation in our country and yet he's put
national insurance up on working people
i think that just tells you all that you
need to know about where the
chancellor's priorities lie and where
the conservatives priorities lie
so so is the labour party no longer as
as lord mandelson once said intensely
relaxed about people getting filthy rich
of course we want to see our economy
growing that's really important for us
we want to see ultimately businesses
growing up and down the country
but what we don't want to have is a
chancellor who seems to be focused on
shielding those who actually have
those means rather than helping others i
mean another example i would say is
around the windfall tax where we've seen
record profits actually being posted by
those oil and gas companies in fact
those companies saying that they're
receiving so much in profits now they
almost don't know what to do with it
well why not use some of that to take
money off people's bills it just doesn't
make sense it's the wrong priorities and
labor has very very different priorities
well is is isn't the point that if the
conservatives are going to steal your
idea and certainly sir kirsten was what
was making making making that point at
pmq's on wednesday they're likely to use
the win fall tax later on in the year
when we've seen prices rise even further
well we want them to steal that idea but
we really want them frankly to steal our
other ideas and our other plans as well
because we know how hard up against it
so many people are we want them to be
getting rid of that national insurance
increase we want them to be taking vat
off bills as i said all of this in terms
of the vat being paid for through
inflated receipts we want them to be
having that mass home insulation program
that we've called for for many many
months getting people's bills down
through that mechanism too we also want
them incidentally to be actually
properly investigating all that covered
fraud now millions and millions and
millions of pounds that could be freed
up to reinvest back in support for
people but the chancellor's saying that
he's actually going to write all of that
fraud off if they steal those ideas
quite frankly both myself and the rest
of the labour party would be overjoyed
not least our shadow chancellor rachel
reeves because we know the difference
those plans would make toward me people